من شان العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه قال
متحدث باسميه البنتاجون ان الوزير اوستن
بحث مع نظيره الصيني في كمبوديا الحاجه
الى الحوار لخفض المخاطر وضروره تعزيز
المحادثات خلال الازمات
مساله طريقه طيران المقاتلات الصينيه
والتي تزيد من مخاطر وقوع الحوادث
الدفاع الامريكي
الى تطبيق الكامل في قرارات مجلس الامن
واعرض عن قلقه من ما وصفها بالاستفزازات
الكوريه الشماليه كما قال لا تنتج عن
الوزير اه استناكد لنظيره الصيني التزام
الولايات المتحده بسياسه الصين الواحده
لذلك افادت وكاله رويترز نقلا عن وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه سبب ما تواجهه بجين مع
واشن حاليا هو احكامها الاستراتيجيه
الخاطئه واضفت انه يجب على الولايات
المتحده احترام المصالح الاساسيه للصين
احمر لا ينبغي تجاوزه وان حله قضيه تايوان
يعود للشعب الصيني وليس من حق اي قوه
خارجيه التدخل